good afternoon
welcome to our daily press briefing
online and live on ebs
today is thursday january 7th
before taking your questions we have uh
two announcements for you
first i would like to call on stefan
with a reminder on the approval of a
second kobe 19 vaccine
in the eu stefan
good morning everybody or good afternoon
radha as you probably already know
yesterday the commission
granted a conditional marketing
authorization for the kovit
19 vaccine developed by moderna which is
the second vaccine to be authorized in
the
eu this authorization follows a positive
recommendation
based on a thorough assessment of the
safety
effectiveness and quality of the vaccine
by european medicine's agency
and it's endorsed by the member states
with this modern vaccine vaccine we will
now have a further 160 million doses
this comes in addition to the 300
million doses of the vaccine distributed
by biotech
pfizer the first vaccine that was
authorized
in the eu on the 21st of december and
more vaccines will follow
europe has secured up to 2 billion doses
of potential
covet 19 vaccines as usual you will find
more information
on our press corner thank you
thank you stephan
johannes scientific
[Music]
bonjour
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh hi no sorry actually on uh
what's up facebook um matters
so i'd like to come back to that later
okay
just hold on one second let's see if
there are other questions
on the us
that does not seem to be the case are
there other questions
on foreign relations
for us today anna
yes hello good morning i have a question
about venezuela
in the council yeah in the council
statement
juan guido has been presented as a
leader of the opposition
and i would like you to ask you to
explain
why he's not recognized anymore as the
interim
president of the country thank you and i
passed the floor to peter on this issue
hi good afternoon anna thank you well
first of all maybe i would stress uh one
thing that
the eu does not recognize or
not recognize representatives or regimes
or
countries or governments or
administrations this is a competence of
individual
and each member state so this is on the
issue of recognition
we can recognize processes such as
elections for example in case of
venezuela
you know very well that we didn't
recognize the elections and their
results
um in december as uh free and democratic
so we are not recognizing
the procedures we don't recognize the
results and as a consequence
we don't recognize the institution which
was formed based on
this process but when it comes to
recognition of people and
representatives this is really
competence of the individual member
states on the declaration itself
this is text agreed and adopted by 27 eu
member states so the text is capturing
the position of the eu and the position
of the eu is saying that we consider
juan guaydo
and the members of the last
democratically elected institution which
is the outgoing
national assembly as particularly
relevant interlocutors
with whom we will continue working with
them in search of
a peaceful sustainable and democratic
solution to the venezuelan crisis
thank you peter are there other
questions
on venezuela
anna you have a follow-up
please but in the pa in the past in
other statements
uh guido was mentioned as president and
now
not anymore so there is a difference and
i would like to understand why this
this evolution
again i think the declaration is quite
clear
what it is dealing with and what it says
so
we believe that this declaration made
very clear our views on juan guido
standing once the mandate of the
national assembly elected in 2015
expired but again this was the text
agreed and adopted by all
27 member states so really not up to me
to go into interpretations
what's in the text is the position of
the european union maybe to add
and preempt any other follow-up
questions on this issue
uh the issue of venezuela will be
discussed at the forthcoming
foreign minister foreign affairs council
this month
so there we might you might have more
answers but at this stage
i would really stick to the text of the
declaration which was
again agreed and adopted by 27 member
states of the eu
thank you i think uh we can move on to
other foreign relations issues and i
pass the floor to
[Music]
[Music]
i now move to momsheel who has a
question on foreign affairs
i believe good afternoon uh my question
is uh related to russia
on uh 28 december at the end of last
year
the russian authorities for the first
time designated
individuals as foreign agents
five russian citizens were designated as
foreign aidans
does the european commission has a have
a comment
about this matter
peter
we seem to have
yes sorry can you now it should be
working right absolutely
okay thank you thank you mom chill um
over the
christmas period or over the holiday
period we issued already a statement on
the issue
so i would refer you to that statement
but i can very briefly recap that of
course we don't agree with this
legislation and we don't agree with the
overall process on this foreign agent's
law
and uh we are urging russia to to stick
to their obligations stemming from from
international commitments
but again i would really refer you to
the to the exact text of
the statement we issued on the issue
okay thank you very much peter um i see
no further foreign affairs related
questions for us today and so i come
back to
oliver oliver you have the floor
hi yes um well uh
what's up announced that from i think
the eighth
of um february onwards all
the data um the person's data of its
users will be transferred to facebook or
will be
well probably not physically transferred
will but will be
accessible to facebook so that includes
your phone number
your address your ip address and also
the contacts you have
that you use through whatsapp there's no
possibility for people to opt out so if
you want to keep using whatsapp you have
to accept
that facebook is using these data for
its commercial purposes
of which we are quite well aware so my
first um
question related to that is does the
commission
think that in light of this uh
move uh its authorization
of the takeover of whatsapp by facebook
uh was justified or that in light of
this
actually the statements and the
presentations by
facebook were probably not correct and
not honest
so that's the competition angle and then
the data safety question
we all use this and also you and the
commission use this in order to
communicate with us
and probably amongst you in light of
this move and also in light of how
facebook is known
to have um abused eu data protection
and breach data protection rules and so
forth do you still think it is
safe for the commission uh to use
whatsapp
from next month onwards in order to
communicate
internally and externally thank you
thank you very much your first question
is
uh certainly for ariana so i passed the
floor to her
good morning eric good morning oliver
and uh and
everyone i hope you can hear and see me
yes we can so i think so
okay so as you know in 2014 we have
cleared
the acquisition of whatsapp by by
facebook
we had of course communicated on it and
why we had cleared the transaction at
that time
uh all i can recall uh at this stage and
i promise that i will get back to you
uh if i have further information uh
later in the course of the day
is that in 2016 we have actually fined
facebook
for um some misleading statements
and not complete information in the
context of the merger procedure
and uh this statements are really
concerned
the technical possibility of
automatically matching
uh facebook and whatsapp's users
identities
which actually already existed in 2014
but
uh were not mentioned to to the
commission
so in 2016 we have actually fined
facebook 110
million euros for this incorrect or
misleading
uh information if i have more i'll get
back to you
later today okay
thank you very much and i will uh pass
the floor to johannes
on the question uh related to the use as
a commission tool
or by commission staff you thank you
eric
um yes indeed uh oliver sometimes we
reply
to colleagues um of yours um on the
means of communication they choose so
sometimes we reply
on whatsapp but internally uh what's up
is not
um the communication tool that we use
already one year ago i think we had the
opportunity to clarify
that the information technology and
cyber security board of the commission
is recommending the use of signal
so this is the application that emerged
as safe in terms of security and privacy
and this is what we
what you use internally for example in
the spp
uh but also more widely of course so
this solution supports the digitization
of the working environment in the
commission
while respecting security priorities and
standards
the use of signal is proposed as a safe
alternative in cases
where no equivalent corporate tool is
available so there is no corporate tools
to use signal
whatsapp is not forbidden to use but
it's for
for example if you have a personal
private conversation with your phone
but once again for work related matters
for you signal
thank you thank you very much
i'm pretty sure that alexander's
question will be
in the same area so alexander go ahead
it's kind of a related question so of
course i'm also interested
in in your response to to the question
specifically and what's
the data sharing but my question
actually concerns the question of what
happens with the messages
so um i'm just writing a piece and i
have looked at how
um the
ombudsman emily o'reilly recently gave
an opinion on the question of whether
sms whatsapp messages other messenger
messages
needs to be archived in the commission
archive to be requested
under regulation 1049 2001.
so ms o'reilly said in her response to
fraction
the german organization that the
regulation and transparency
uh is is regardless of the form of uh
in which a message was is being sent but
the commission replied to me in another
on another inquiry that currently there
is no technical framework to even save
sms messages or whatsapp messages
in internal communication so my question
would be will the commission
react to the ombudsman and start
archiving sms and whatsapp messages at
other messenger messages
um i don't i'm not sure that we are able
to answer that question here
on the podium so we will come back to
you alexander
bilaterally on this what i can say is
that
indeed what is important is the content
of a conversation not the medium
through which this conversation is being
held this is what the regulation
says and therefore the rules that are
uh that are supposed to be uh that are
supposed to be applied if something is
considered like
a phone conversation with no no specific
contact exchange then than not if there
is specific policy related content then
it should be
uh then it should be archived whether
it's then technically feasible or not we
will have to come back to you
on whether we are doing something on it
or not
okay i give the floor to christian
christian pardo who's the only one with
his hand raised
christian we say
[Music]
security
follow
[Music]
uh
[Music]
okay i now open the floor to other
subjects and i give the
floor to berkeley
yeah hi um here from politico i just got
a quick question to see if there's a
reaction
from the u.s treasury's investigations
into digital services taxes
specifically in spain and italy thank
you
thank you um i'm not sure whether it is
for miriam or
for
at this stage
yes i can repeat what i said yesterday
we still have not
received any notification from the us
authority so we cannot comment further
at this stage
true you had answered the question
yesterday apologies for that
thank you any other questions for us
today
that does not seem to be the case so
thank you very much and
see you tomorrow